my name is David thorburn I'm a
professor of literature and comparative
media studies and the director of the
MIT Communications Forum it's my uh
truly happy privilege to introduce uh
our speakers today two of whom are close
friends and colleagues of mine and I uh
took on the introduction task in part
because I feared that if I allowed uio
to do the introduction he would be too
modest
and uh uh as a as a as the senior member
of the CMS faculty I have the right to
brag about my colleagues uh I I so my
plan then is to introduce the three
speakers and turn things over to William
uio who is really the official moderator
and controller of the
discussion let me Begin by introducing
my colleagues Henry Jenkins and William
uio
uh both are prolific influential
Scholars Visionary teachers and
lecturers and Shapers of a program here
at MIT that I think in 10 or 15 years
will be recognized as one of the
signature achievements of the
Institute perhaps the only major
difference between Jenkins and uo in a
sort of intellectual or moral sense is
that uio is visionary with a better
fashion
sense
but they're both riveting uh uh thinkers
and and and uh Scholars about the
relationships between Old and New Media
which is of course one of our
fundamental topics today as you know
Jenkins is the director of the
comparative media studies program he is
the Peter def Floren professor of
humanities at MIT and his most recent
book outside here on the front in which
uh uh one of his uh blurbs Compares him
to mclan and says that Henry is the 21st
century mclan I think myself that
underestimates Henry but that that has
to do with that partly has to do with
with with my sense of mclan uh uh it is
it it is a uh uh in any case uh uh the
the book has just appeared and in some
sense it's a kind of a distillation or
summary of things that Jenkins has been
teaching and writing about for for many
years I'm sure the book will have a
powerful and significant impact on uh
American culture and on especially on on
our understanding of emerging
media William uro equally distinguished
as a scholar has specialized us uh
particularly in in the in an earlier
moment of transition and my hope is that
he will uh be more than merely a
moderator today that he'll that he'll
bring his own knowledge of that moment
when the When when when when the movies
appeared in in in Europe in European and
American culture to bear on our our
discussion today uh he is with Henry the
co-director of the comparative media
studies program at MIT and he also holds
a uh a a a professorship in comparative
media history in the Netherlands at the
University of utre his most recent book
is entitled media cultures and it's
about responses to media in the in post
911 Germany and the United States uh
it's a uh been a privilege and a and and
and an educ ation to work with William
and Henry these years and I over these
years and I'm particularly pleased that
they're taking part in our discussion
today our third speaker Yokai Ben
benkler is a professor of law at Yale
University where he teaches
communication and information law he is
the author of many articles uh uh on
aspects
of of our emerging digital Universe uh
and many of them deal with aspects of
what we might we we might identify as as
the question of of of a digital Commons
or of a of of a space protected from or
separate from traditional Market forces
and he's been he's some of his essays I
think have been immensely creative in
this way and he is as most of you now
know the author of a book that's been
hailed again and again uh by people both
inside the territory of cyber studies
and New Media and by uh more traditional
sorts of folks who might be thought to
normally ignore such things the book of
course is called the wealth of networks
how social production transforms markets
and
freedom we had a speaker here uh Tuesday
part of this series on newspapers who
told a small gathering of CMS graduate
students and faculty that he thought
that benger's book was the most
important book of the year now of course
this was he hadn't seen Jenkins book yet
so that maybe but but but in but in any
case this is a kind of characteristic
response to uh Yokai Banker's work and I
might add that that uh one of the things
that has struck me about the response to
Banker's work has been uh this that in
those environments where one might not
expect an automatic Embrace an automatic
enthusiasm for the sorts of ideas that
bankler is suggesting in his book for
example in places like the times
literary supplement the London Times
literary supplement or in the in the uh
New York Review of Books uh the reviews
that he's been getting from literary and
traditional public intellectual types
even when they have disagreed with him
have been remarkably respectful and and
uh uh civil and I think it's a mark of
the power of His argument that he's
beginning to sort of reach out his
argument is beginning to reach outside
of the territories where such discourse
is congenial and usually
accepted as you all know we're we're
we're engaged engaged in a kind of
ongoing conversation about the future of
newspapers and the nature of news and
information in our digital future and I
want to uh uh offer a special thanks to
the CMS graduate students who have been
uh constituting what I take to be now
the sort of core audience of this of
this um uh Venture My Hope Is that those
of you who have returned for our second
conversation today and we'll return
again on October 5th for our final uh
installment of the of these discussions
will help us to keep the discourse on
point uh it's I'm very I'm and I want to
indicate my my my my gratitude
especially to the to the audience and my
hope that the audience will will will
continue to make the kind of
intellectual contribution to our
discourse that has been the mark of
communications Forum events
William David thanks very much for the
uh the warm words I think on behalf of
all of us the very warm words um I guess
I would agree with uh the person you
mentioned that these we're sitting here
with the authors of the two most
important books that I've read this year
that's definitely for sure uh both books
charting a course through a profound
moment of of media change not just media
change but societal change um both books
alert us to an array of possibilities
and also to the dangers posed by the
status quo and some of its institutional
presences and what I think is really
terrific about having the two here at
the table besides the fact that they've
been sort of trailing one another in
series form in many different venues uh
uh yohai appears and Henry shows up a
week later or vice versa this is the
first face-to-face meeting and what's
terrific about the work is is the
reciprocity of the work Henry's
convergence culture moves from the
cultural that is to say the domain of
fan activities bloggers and hackers
towards ultimately the
social and um Kai's work uh book The
Wealth of Nations sorry the wealth of
networks with it's referen to Adam Smith
I mean it's got the ambition sorry yeah
it certainly has the ambition and I
think delivers uh we will see in another
generation or so but I think it is as
seminal as Adam Smith's work um moves
from the social that is to say the
notion of information economy legal and
uh polish policy choices towards the
cultural so although they're coming from
two very different directions in fact
they're occupying the same terrain um
the format will be that uh each speaker
will talk for about 15 minutes lay out
their positions and then I'll have a few
questions and we'll open it to the floor
and take it from there
so well great
thank too many nice things said about
you so I'm uncomfortable um it is is is
truly great uh uh and wonderful to be
here
um uh I'm I'm I'm thrilled to be able to
talk to you I'm thrilled to be able to
talk to Henry uh this this uh hopefully
should be great fun uh I'm assuming um
uh a lot of knowledge so I will be even
more telegraphic than I usually am which
for anybody who's already heard me speak
should be scary um but let me try to do
this in 15 minutes so that we have a lot
of time for conversation um and I want
to talk about the economics of uh uh
social production and then spend some
time talking about the politics uh uh
which will be the place where I think I
I'll be able to do the most work tying
into uh journalism so first the
economics let's go back 150 years
between 1835 and 1850 the cost of
starting what was understood as a mass
circulation new Daily Newspaper in New
York jumped from what is roughly a th
$10,000 in 2005 terms to roughly $25
million and the difference between
$2,000 and 2 and a half Millions is that
for 2 and a half million you need a
business model what we saw around this
this change in the technological and
organizational structure is a stark
bifurcation between consumers and
producers with passive large audiences
and professional and particularly in the
US commercial producers organized in one
of the two ways in which we knew how to
collect capital in the industrial period
markets or States this ends up repeating
itself not always for technical reasons
sometimes for policy uh uh choices uh in
radio and television and satellite and
cable and the main frame until we get to
the network computer here's another
image scare and fear in the United
States in the middle of 2002 the fastest
supercomputer is no longer produced by
an American company paid for by the
American government it is a Japanese
company paid for by the Japanese
government very scary side relief
collectively two years later IBM just
inches out the NC Earth simulator
everyone at the same time ignoring that
throughout this entire period SE at home
dwarves both of these 4 and a half
million computer users sharing their
leftover computer Cycles when they're
not doing any work what I'm I trying to
capture with this image what we're
seeing here is not decline in capital
intensity overall it's the radical
decentralization of capitalization
computation storage and
Communications get distributed in the
population
so that every connected person somewhere
between 600 million and a billion people
has the physical capital means necessary
to
engage in information knowledge and
cultural
production this creates a new condition
where the most important inputs into the
core economic activities of the most
advanced economies are widely
distributed in the population that is
computation and Communications resources
and human creativity intuition
experience and motivation which are held
by individuals are non-f fungible and
are widely distributed in the
population what this does critically is
take behaviors that were once on the
periphery of the economy widespread but
on the periphery of the economy things
like having coffee with friends stopping
to answer a stranger on the street when
they ask you for directions move from
things we do because we're human beings
to things that compete with Market
activities that create Market demands
that can be inputs into economic
production that can be things that
platforms economically are built to do
we see the emergence of Commons based
production as a much more significant
Force which is to say production without
exclusion from the inputs production
without exclusion from the outputs which
can be individual or collaborative can
be commercial or non-commercial the
critical feature is that in addition to
to the physical capital availability to
act one also has the formal authority to
act with it there is no property rule
that says You must ask permission a
major an major important subset of
common based production is peer
production by which I mean large scale
cooperation among human contributors
that does not depend on either the other
traditional decentralized model of
coordination the price system or on
centralized coordination through uh for
hierarchies we also see this happening
and the economics are a little bit
different because the underlying
resources are different in sharing of
material resources when they're widely
distributed in the population
distributed computing Wireless net
meshwork distributed storage various
mixtures like Skype we won't talk much
about these today what we see what are
we talking about we're talking about
free and open source software for
example would you imagine in 1996 if
somebody told you that a bunch of
volunteers was starting to build a web
server because they understood the web
was was important and Microsoft did the
same thing they over the next decade
through boom and bus the main
application that manages the e-commerce
applications everywhere 20 or 30% of the
market would be volunteers and 60 70%
would be Microsoft you'd say that's
insane but of course the reality is the
opposite it's Apache that has the 60 or
70% through boom and bust uh uh
throughout these periods um we are
seeing things happen like Mars click
workers already old at this point of
people
tens of thousands of people marking
images coming in from Mars because the
problem is chunked up and
generating
Maps uh as volunteers at the rate at
which the images are coming in and when
it's measured at high
quality there are arguments about
Wikipedia right how good is it exactly
how does it compare to britanica but if
you stop for a moment and see in 2001 in
February this guy Jimmy Wales puts on a
thousand stubs more or less and an
interface that allows anybody to do
whatever the damn please about the thing
and you would sit there and say you know
what in about five years this will be
arguably as good as
britanica
ludicrous and so we have this nature
article four years and 10 months later
that does exactly this and sends out
definitions to practicing scientists and
what do practicing scientists say about
science definitions in britanica and
Wikipedia they're both
crappy to roughly the same extent and
that's the critical point and there are
arguments about the quality of this
study but that doesn't matter what
matters is that it's a plausible
argument four years and 10 months
later we can keep talking about Slash
talk about flicker about delicious I
don't need to tell you they're all over
the place we're also seeing things like
uh connections effort to
apply peer production to particular
production problems like for example
teaching materials and getting teach
teachers to be able to collaborate on
producing teaching materials together so
as I said common based peer production
the radical Authority and practical
capability to act which allows for self-
selection Taps diverse motivations
particularly intrinsic and social
relational Taps diverse insights and
capabilities and availability the whole
knowledge movement Knowledge Management
movement over the last decade in
business schools has been about the
problematics of deciding how of figuring
out how to manage knowledge production
this is done now in a decentralized form
we see diverse cooperation platform
doing a lot of things and I can happily
go into that later I don't want to go
into all of the details of how this is
broken down allowing self- selection
allowing communication allowing people
to interpret what they're doing as a
social human uh act creating Norms trust
Etc basically what we see is that we
used to have three
models market-based models could be
decentralized or centralized the price
system in FBS if you wanted something
that could be done outside that needed
to be done outside of the market but you
still needed to collect the capital you
did it through government or you did it
through traditional nonprofits and what
we see now is the emergence of social
sharing and exchange as a major
additional modality of production this
creates new competition we all know
these stories PTP recording industry
free and software Wikipedia Etc also New
Opportunities from well- behaved
appliances to production tools from
bifurcated consumer and infrastructure
Goods to dual use machines like Wi-Fi or
Skype and what will matter for us here
from finished information and cultural
Goods to platforms for self-expression
and collaboration be it uh Garage Band
be it multiplayer online games be it
something like technorati a lot of what
comes in under this broad uh uh uh vague
umbrella term of Web 2.0 we see Surfers
people make contracts because they say
stuff will flow out of connected human
beings and I'm so sure of this that I
will make a commitment that I will
deliver such and such on such and such a
day for such and such an amount sounds
crazy crazy I'll pay people to
participate in this but I won't own any
of it sounds crazy until you looked at
IBM's revenues the largest patent holder
uh uh in the United States uh green is
patent revenues blue is Linux related
Services uh
revenues look at the BBC they learn the
only images from inside the underground
are people with their camera
phones so now they're beginning to work
with help us make the news what do you
have and just this morning I was talking
to people in public broadcasting and the
person from the BBC who's been working
on this is talking about the problems of
how to manage the traditional culture of
the BBC with this new model but they
understand that there's enormous power
there so social production is a real
fact not a fad it's the critical
long-term shift caused by the internet
in some context it's more efficient than
markets or firms it's sustainable and
growing fast but is is a threat to and
is threatened by incumbent business
models when we look at intellectual
property t Communications and a variety
of other new and funky laws they are the
battlefield where the incumbents are
trying to make it expensive and hard to
do these new
things which brings me to the
politics how we understand the world how
we communicate about it how we know what
the state of the world is how we talk
about how it might be and who wants to
do what are Central to both freedom and
Justice so how we produce information
knowledge and culture then plays in to
autonomy to democracy to Justice and
development and I won't go through all
of these now but let me tell you a story
that will I think help us uh understand
how this meets so as you may recall in
200000 uh the US had something of a of
of of some some irregularities in
questions of voting and so in 2002 there
were uh people introduced voting
machines in Georgia you would have
thought the mainstream media would cover
this but in fact there was all almost
nothing all there was were a few stories
people are worried but we're told by so
and so that it'll be okay and by so and
so that there'll be a lot of support and
of course so and so is the person
selling the machines and such and such
is the person who bought them from the
person selling the machines uh and
that's it one uh uh one activist finds
the source code puts it on her own site
puts it also on a New Zealand site and
this is what's different here if you
look at the way that it's set up so here
are the materials see for
yourself we might be subject to people
trying to shut us down make
copies not make sure we can sue against
an injunction make copies some of these
things are corrupt uh some of the files
are password protected but here are
these nice people from Lost password.com
they'll help you some of these things
won't run properly but here are these
nice people from zip repair um they'll
help you we have no money to pay anybody
to look through these and and try to
figure it out but it's really important
if you find anything post it here um
we'll make clear and in fact it does
happen and we have iy ruin from John's
Hopkins doing an analysis Maryland
reading that doing another couple of
studies and requiring modifications B
Harris then becomes a node and when
somebody finds a cash of emails sends it
to her and sends it to wire how does
wire report on it can you believe these
idiots lost their stuff again and that's
it what does m Harris do I know what to
do I'll put them up this time however
debol knows what to do we have digital
minum Copyright Act these emails they're
ours and you can't have them copyright
take them down end of story not quite
because some sore students replicate
them and have them up but Debo knows
what to
do the MCA letter you have to bring them
down end of story
no no because at that point a network of
individuals and
collaborations of legal actors and
illegal actors and quasi legal actors of
commercial actors and free software
developers create an
ecology that
replicates resists persists bringing
ultimately to the case where a few
Californians find as they're looking
through these emails that it turns out
that many of these machines are not the
machines that were
certified and so there's this great
dramatic moment where somebody comes as
they're about to certify the machine
says wait fa Mason moment wait I've got
these emails and after two months almost
more than half of the machines get
decertified now it's not that law wasn't
there ultimately to protect them they
win that a declaratory judgment that
it's not copyright infringement that
it's free but it comes a year later
that's too late to affect the results of
the returns what is
effective is this
system not the
law so we can talk about this later more
democratic after all no not everyone a
pamphleteer but what we is a structured
web that offers visibility to more
people in accreditation and filtration
clusters that allow people to figure out
what they care more free of the
constraints on speech though not
perfectly so emphasizing what's
intensely interesting to groups of
people who are intensely interested as
opposed to what's moderately interesting
to very large audiences where interest
comes from is important and I hope we
get a chance to talk about that later
very strong linking practices a very
strong SE for yourself culture um and
and easier to form purposive
Association um I won't talk about
critical culture uh uh uh but but it's
obviously part of of of of this both uh
the reemergence of folk culture and the
transparency and legibility of the
materials I'll just say about 50 words
about Justice in an information economy
a global information economy more of
what makes for human welfare and
development depends on information
knowledge and culture be it health and
life expectancy this is the human
development index components education
and literacy or GDP per capita each of
these is dependent on information
embedded tools information embedded
Goods information and knowledge books
and teaching materials food security
medicines all of growth driven by
Innovation and each feeding into each
other and what we're beginning to see is
Commons based and peer production
beginning to help by no stretch of the
imagination of Panacea in free and open
source software for purposes of of of of
critical infrastructures in open
academic public Ing and perhaps
beginning on open Learning Materials
open source and agricultural Innovation
we're beginning to see the biof forge
trying to replicate sour Forge for
purposes of biological Innovation
initially in agriculture maybe in other
area certainly bioinformatics with the H
map hype mapping uh project efforts at
open source Biomet so here's a free high
school s text from from uh uh South
Africa here's the hapmap project here's
bios biological Innovation for an open
Society because of the battles because
of the fear of the competition we're
seeing a battle of the institutional
environment at all levels on physical
infrastructure on machines on software
on on on content and the law keeps
flipping the toggles mostly in favor of
the incumbents but social practices
political resistance Market drives of
people who actually can make money from
serving what it is that people want um
uh are pushing back so technological
threshold conditions enable greater
individual human agency social sharing
and exchange emerge as a major modality
of economic production we're beginning
to practice new ways of being free and
equal human beings but this is subject
to a global and persistent political
battle the stakes of which are how we
become more
productive but also more free and equal
as human
beings
all right um as William suggests we uh
we the Two of Us come at this question
more or less the same set of questions
from different disciplinary and
theoretical perspectives that is we
fundamentally agree I think this is not
going to be a classic debate in any
stretch of the imagination because on
most every issue that we're going to
think of I think there's a general
consensus about what we think happening
and what some of its larger implications
are but how we approach that question is
very different and for for me I'm
starting from the re from the
perspective of someone who's researched
fan cultures popular culture mass media
and moving toward a perspective on what
we're what we're going to call in this
discussion Civic media uh which includes
not just news and journalism but large
all of those media that we rely on to
Define our connection to each other and
Define that structure of feeling we
might call of citizenship and that's
that's really the starting point I'm
going to I'm going to make in terms of
the topic we have on the table here um
on the screen you have the covers of two
new books I have coming out and I'm
going to talk just briefly about the
Star Wars picture under on the fans
bloggers and Gamers cover the other one
is not actually the cover of my book it
gets changed but I there's a reason why
I still have this image here uh the
picture of the Stormtroopers is
interesting this is a picture that
appeared in newspapers across the US
after the more recent most recent Star
Wars films came out on DVD as a said it
got enormous pickup by the mass media it
had on interestingly enough Lucas film
had absolutely nothing to do with his
image right this was a guy a fan dressed
up in a stormtrooper uniform went to his
local Tor R Us his friend took a picture
with a cell phone camera they uploaded
it to flicker they notified the media
and this was in newspapers around the
country and I've had such great fun
Imagine
Lucas and his company's response mixed
feelings at this image hitting the news
on the one hand this is great publicity
they couldn't pay for this kind of
publicity on the other hand they had no
control over the message and for a
traditional mass media organization
that's a source of enormous anxiety that
loss of control the sense that your
consumer could say what they want and
affect the fortunes of a major Hollywood
release to some degree I mean we don't
want to exaggerate the degree to which
this picture shaped The Fortunes of star
but it did have a dent or impact on the
Public's perception all right to the
other picture here let me go to a bigger
version of that picture on the TV screen
below this is an image called from a s
website called Bird is
evil and Bird is evil did a series of
Photoshop ju appositions of Bert from
Sesame Street with it's caught in a
variety of scandalous situations Bert in
bed with Pamela Anderson Bert on the
grassy null during the Kennedy
assassination Bert waving flags as a clu
clux Clan member
and here Bert with Bin Laden and this
was done by a Filipino American High
School student who put up this website
it was popular on the web like so many
YouTube phenomenons maybe lonely girl 15
or whatnot it bubbled up but what
happened next no one was prepared for
which is after September 11th uh in
Pakistan and Bangladesh protesters
constructed a poster uh of images of Bin
Laden and they did it by scanning the
web grabbing attractive images of B and
slapping it on there and if you look
closely you will see there's Burton Bin
Laden is part of this image that was
waved by hordes of angry anti-American
protesters following September 11th and
was captured by CNN's cameras and
broadcast to the world which prompted
the folks at Children's television
Workshop to threaten to sick their
intellectual property lawyers on someone
and I you know and I've I've been having
great fun Imagining the Bush
Administration unable to find find the
cave in Pakistan where Bin Laden is but
the intellectual property attorneys from
a children's television Workshop
tracking him down and hitting him in a
cease in the cyst order uh for their use
of Bert's image uh now as you think
about the story what we're seeing is a
number of things the the interplay of
top down and bottom up media the
interplay of sort of broadcast media
Sesame Street CNN a bottomup media
whether it's the original website we're
talking about the Bird is evil side or
the post maker in the Middle East both
of them in a kind of Collision Course
where they affect each other's fortunes
and the message that emerges the media
culture that emerges is shaped top up
and Bot top down and bottom up it's
shaped both by decisions made in
teenagers bedrooms and decisions made in
corporate boardrooms and the
intellectual property attorneys are
struggling to make sense of a sh a
regime that is changing out from
underneath them so fast that they really
can't understand the terms in which the
culture is
operating so this is what I mean by
conver convergence I'm not talking about
a technological process this is two
images of convergence by the way a
corporate perspective is talking about
the orchestration across media and a
protest site talking about Bill Gates as
the Borg absorbing everything this is
the debate about convergence as we see
it and it's not to my mind a
fundamentally technological process it's
not about which Black Box will all the
media in our lives flow through it's a
fundamentally cultural process that if
if we wait for the black boxes to
resolve themselves I think we got a long
way because on the one hand in my Liv
room in more black boxes than ever
before and the the remotes are in the
couch Christians the cords are Tangled
nothing works through each other on the
ground convergence is a clu above ground
but on the other hand if we say talk
about convergence is a cultural process
and we say do we live in a world where
every story is going to every image
every sound every brand every
relationship is going to be conducted
across the maximum number of media
channels legally or illegally
corporately or at an amateur level then
I think we have to say we already live
in a convergence culture that all these
things are working together to ensure
the flow of media whether it's top- down
media organizations controlling all of
the visions of the entertainment sector
the five companies everyone's concerned
about or whether we're talking about
Grassroots interest taking media where
they want it when they want it how they
want it in whatever form they want it Le
illegally if it's not available to them
legally those two forces meet together
to form what I'm calling
convergence so convergence is understood
you know an orchestrated way trans media
storytelling I talk in the book about
participatory culture you know the idea
that our culture is going to be more
participatory but that no one is sure
what the terms of participation is so
even within a company mix signals
conflicts fans are uncertain what their
rights are so forth and then the flip
side of that is what we might call
experimental experiential marketing love
marks viral marketing the advertising
world there's a variety of ways of
talking about the fact they want to
quote Empower us as consumers to spread
the message about their brand so
everyone's describing a world that's
going to be more participatory that's
going to be more transm
medient what we're not talking about
again is interactive Technologies that's
the old category and I see interactivity
as a property of technological design
and that's very very important what
we're talking about is participatory
cultures and I'm using the term
participation to refer what cultures
bring to the table whether it's part of
the technology or not so the contrast
here is the iPod which is organized as
an interactive technology to enable
certain flows of music and podcasting
which is a form of participatory culture
that emerges around that technology
seizes it and pulls it in its own its
own Direction so I'm interested in
participation which is sort of outside
the box that shapes the way the box is
used and of course what's taking place
inside the box has affordances and
resistances that affect what you can do
with it key to this in the Civic sphere
is a concept of collective intelligence
which I take from Pure Levy right and
what Levy is telling us is that in a
network Society more and more we're
creating new sources of power that
emerge as people are able people from
diverse backgrounds are able to pull
knowledge as Levy puts it in a world of
collective intelligence nobody knows
everything everybody knows some things
and what's known by Any Given member is
available to the group as a whole on a
moment's notice it is to use another
term floating around right now Cory Do's
turn and adhocracy in which groups from
very different backgrounds put
information together to serve common
purposes and it changes the abil the
collective intelligence the ability of
this community to process information is
a very different order than the ability
the inform of the individual we saw it
in the example about the black voting
boxes I saw it a decade ago when I was
looking at fans response to Twin Peaks
versus the average viewer's response
average viewer was saying Twin Peaks was
becoming so complicated no one could
understand it the fan Community is
saying Twin Peaks is becoming so dummy
down and simple I'm bored by it wasn't
the fans were more smart than more
intelligent than the average viewer it
is collectively they process the
information at a faster rate they were
able to combine knowledge in new ways
they're experimenting with a new source
of power that grows out of the ability
to process
information all of this contributes into
what I'm calling participatory culture
and people say well you know you have
some people are becoming more
participatory this is some statistics
from Pew looking at high school students
and done study done last year found 57%
of teens who use the internet are media
producers right so there's still a
concern about the 43% and we can talk
about what I call the participation Gap
later but the point is that this is a
generation of media producers and media
producers that by and large are
producing media and response to mass
media and that's where I think the in
the interest again in the top down
bottom up stuff becomes very interesting
you know I people say we live in a world
where five companies control the flow of
media into our lives and I say yes
that's probably true other people say we
live in a world where there are no
Gatekeepers and anyone can post anything
they want and I Sayes that's true the
point is we treat those as parts of an
elephant and we haven't talked about the
relationship between those two things
and the degree to which mass media
provides the content that in
participatory culture absorbs reworks
transforms appropriates recirculates and
so forth now what does this have to do
with Civic media I'm going to now sort
of pull away from the space of pop
culture and into news media just a
little bit although I hope to blur the
lines between them in this presentation
because I don't think there's a simple
line in this you know the same way that
top down and bottom up or blur the
notion of what is news and information
and what is entertainment are blurring
what a citizen is what a fan is are
blurring in some fundamental ways we're
at a period of time Levi uses the term
an apprenticeship stage where we're
acquiring skills at participatory
culture and collective intelligence
we're learning how to do it and right
now I'm arguing we acquire those skills
more readily in our recreational lives
and our Civic lives that right now we're
acquiring skills as fans and Gamers and
bloggers it circulate around games
around popular culture culture and so
forth and those skills are rapidly being
deployed by other sectors by education
by religion by the military by
advertising by by you know political
activist groups that the skills that are
acquired from fan cultures translate
into new forms of activism on a really
rapid basis so interestingly enough we
both have slides of the London Bomb
Blast and it's an example of where
amateurs carrying cell phones collected
images of the blast in London put them
up on Flicker and they became a kind of
very important record of took place the
same thing took place around Katrina and
the images that are generated there of
average people uh sort of sharing images
of the street and it changed the
coverage of Katrina I think you people
always talk about Anderson Cooper and
what he did on the television news but I
think if people were not hearing
firsthand reports and seeing firsthand
images through a
variety channels the criticism against
the bush administration's handling of
krina would have played out on a very
different basis and I think the fact
that people are carrying cell phone
cameras around collecting data sharing
data at the present time is part of what
led to that context and here's some some
of the images that amateurs took of
Katrina that look very different from
the first wave of images we saw through
the mass media following Katrina at the
same time people were using this this
Pro process to critique media coverage
right this is a website that just put
images from different newspapers up and
the captioning that the whole point was
that these white people were finding
bread and soda where this black person
was looting a grocery store right you
couldn't tell it from the pictures but
the caption clearly makes a moral
distinction between one group of people
taking food and
another current a launch is at about you
know is another example of the Civic
media Al Gore is television network lots
of the cont the idea is much of the
contents generated by amateurs with
camcorders recording their own media
editing and uploading it to its site
user moderation and so forth there user
participation is taken for granted
access to your local cable distributor
is maybe a bit of a problem and that's
where you see where bottom up and people
staring saying why should I go through
the narrow pipeline of a commercial
Network to get on cable when Al Gore
can't Al Gore the former Vice President
of the United States can't get his
Network into many systems around the
country but I on Flickr and YouTube can
get my images up overnight and have them
seen by people and tap this Grassroots
Channel That's starting to publicize
things here's bush in 30 seconds U Move
On ran a campaign where people you made
anti-bush commercials and they were
uploaded on the web and judged and how
many of those people started by making
Star Wars fan videos or skateboarding
films they use the equipment and learned
how to use it through rature Grassroots
pop culture and began applying it and
the model for this comes really from
Project Greenlight which was a reality
television show and then the produc the
organizers of this campaign acknowledg
that's where they got the idea for this
approach from this is talking about
Katrina uh the group The Legendary KO
our hip-hop group from Houston started
recording stories from Refuge GES at the
asome that they felt were not being told
in the mainstream media they recorded
them as a song which in fact called
George Bush doesn't care about black
people sampled Kai West the song went up
on the web for free within two weeks it
went platinum in traditional terms the
number of downloads of the song was
equal to the number of sales of a top
selling record with no publicity
campaign no major label simply the
bloggers sphere picking this thing up
promoting it rendering it more Vis more
visible for public discussion it it
makes true what Chuck D had talked about
a long time ago that hip hop and digital
distribution would be the black band CNN
that is the ability of people to record
immediate responses to public events
outside of the framework of the
mainstream media and put them into
circulation people would begin to be
drawn to that and you would begin to see
story stuff bubbling up and this is a
good illustration of that
process right thinking again about
Katrina the ability of amateurs to
juxtapose news photographs and ways to
make commentary is very much part of
this what I jokingly in the book call
Photoshop for democracy but it's you
know this is an example coming out of
Katrina this is uh another kind of
example of Photoshop collage
uh uh this is another example of the
kind of images that people are
generating at the present time let's
think of these as the equivalent of
editorial cartoons that is they're not
deep they're not profound what they do
is encapsulate a public policy debate in
a single image that is potent enough
that at least makes you laugh and think
and pass it along to someone else but
the ability of these images and the
tools to create this is a space of
public commentary I think is changing
some of the ways we think about current
events and issues this is a scene from a
film called a film called frch democracy
it's a It's Made on using the game
engine the movies movies was designed to
take Machinima tools and make them more
widely accessible and it was the for one
of the first highly publicized use of it
was a response to the student protest in
in in France and Peter moleno who made
the game is really excited by the fact
that it's being used for political
purposes right off the bat so we're
seeing more and more young people drawn
toward popular politics by their
commitments to popular culture voting as
fans be whether it's through MTV's Rock
the vote or other sorts of movements and
we're also seeing in a network Society
television content becoming the center
of political debates television does
important work in this not this is not
just about stand speaking in a vacuum
but it's about the work as Civic media
that entertainment may play to provoke
discussions and part of the power as I
said wrote in my blog recently that we
watch westwing and in blue States and we
watch 24 in red States right is a
paraphrase of Barack Obama that as we
watch the same TV shows across political
lines the blogers sphere becomes
increasingly partisan and split and
Schism communication around television
enables conversations that might not
occur elsewhere westwing last seon did a
really interesting thing of mirroring
two purple candidates that is people use
the term purple to talk about candidates
who straddle red and blue politics that
is we have a John McCain Republican
versus a Barack Obama democrat in the in
the main narrative and they model
different rhetorical framings of the
political debate that suggest ways out
of a purely partisan divided election
and around that there was enormous
discussion by activists and by fans
about which of those ideas could work in
the real world and which couldn't the
present one of those debates I think is
taking place around Survivor there has
many there been a lot of controversy
about survivor's decision have a
racially segregated cast the season and
I think one of the productive things out
of it and I have mixed feelings about it
one of the productive things is it
forced a it's forcing a real discussion
about race and its place in America
today among people who normally avoid
the topic that people are asking
questions about race discussing race a
lot of ugliness is coming out but a lot
of also correction is coming out that
the choice to have a show where you have
four races not too already challenges
the dormal framing of race and American
culture that the that the discussion
involves a world where whites are now in
the minority and that it's a major
majority minority population on that
island already forces people to think
about some of the demographic shifts in
American culture I see the debate that
it creates is valuable whether or not
the show did it for a ratings push or
whatnot the fact we now have this world
where television content can be
political the fan discussions around it
as Grassroots and maybe a space for
discussions that would not take place in
more heavily charged political channels
says something about what's going to be
needed for civic media to get us out of
the partisan divide that we're currently
in so I see more hope when I look at
games communities and fan communities
from bipartisan discussion then I see
when I look at discussions on newspaper
list and things that are normally
defined as political and so that's where
I'm going to end my opening remarks but
it suggest I think some of the ways that
I'm getting from talking about popular
culture to talking about political
culture or Civic Media or news media but
I think there's some interesting Trends
there that we really want to pay
attention
to okay so we thought we would just have
a little segue to U sort of In Time
demonstration of some of the things that
both speakers have talked about here
produced media networked uh blurring the
lines between producer and user blurring
the fact fiction divide one more example
and then we'll be off to the
discussion
[Applause]
can be true or false I leave such
judgments to you
insector our Story begins as these
stories often do with a young upand
cominging
politician he's a deeply religious man
and a member of the conservative party
he completely single-minded and has no
regard for political process the more
power he attains the more obvious his
Zeet the more aggressive is support is
become if your ultimate goal is power
how best to use such a weapon at this
point in our story that along comes a
spider is without a conscience For Whom
the ends always justify the means and it
is he who suggests that their target
should not be an enemy of the country
but rather the country itself
three targets are chosen to maximize the
effect of the attack fueled by the media
fear and panic spread quickly fracturing
and dividing the country until at last
the true goal comes into view eventually
several extremists have tried found
guilty and executed while a memorial is
built to canonize their
victims but the end result the true
genius of the plan was the
fear fear became the ultimate tool of
this government and through it as party
launches a special CR project in the
name of National Security the first is
believed to be a search for biological
weapons and it's pursued without regard
to its
cost however the true goal of this
project is power complete and total
hegemonic
domination what we need right now is a
clear message to the people of this
country this message must be read in
every newspaper heard on every radio
seen on every television this message
must ReSound throughout the enti High
inell link I want this country to
realize that we stand on the edge of
Oblivion I want every man woman and
child to understand how close we are the
chaos I want everyone to remember why
they need us killing us truth is there
is something terribly wrong with this
country isn't there cruelty and
Injustice intolerance and depression and
where once you had the freedom to object
to think and speak as you s fit you now
have sensors and systems of surveillance
coercing your Conformity and sub your
submission cameras how did this happen
who's to blame well certainly there are
those who are more responsible than
others they will be held accountable but
again truth be told if you're looking
for the guilty you need only look into a
mirror I know why you did it I know you
were afraid who wouldn't be War Terror
disease there were a myriad of problems
conspired to corrupt your reason and Rob
you of your common sense fear got the
best of you he promised you order he
promised you peace and all he demanded
in return was your silent obedient
consent so if you've seen nothing if the
crimes of this government remain unknown
to you then I would suggest that you
allow the 5th of November to pass
unmarked but if you see what I see if
you feel as I feel and if you would seek
as I seek then I ask her to stand beside
outside the gates of Parliament and
together we shall give them a fifth of
November that shall never ever be
[Music]
forgotten okay so I'm not sure how many
of you have seen the film but the the
Logics of the film as well as this
little remix are kind of evident again
it speaks to lots of dimensions of
what's been discussed as well as the
problem of how we evaluate
Fox News or CNN news or whatever but the
question in my very limited time that my
that I that I'd like to put forward
actually has to do with what we know
Henry I think mentioned this notion of
the that we're in The Apprentice stage
we have a new set of realities a new set
of practices they're they're obviously
growing very quickly how do we need to
enable what do we need to do to enable
our our citizenry to be able to
critically and actively engage with with
this is it a matter of porting over
existing skill sets for example Notions
of accuracy from present day
journalistic practice Notions of
attribution um do we need to sort of
train people in what currently exists
those relatively long-term Traditions or
is it a matter of generating new sets of
skills in comparativ in uh the notion of
thinking about news as a process rather
than as a set and series of facts where
do we have to lean in order to make Max
maximum advantage of this to especially
in the terms of of Civic engagement that
we're here to talk a bit about you you
want
to you're you're the guest go ahead
um I'm a little baffled about who we are
and who we're
teaching
um uh um and I think that's a little
indicative of uh the the very different
framework um uh there's a context in
which when you think that there
is a uh relatively well- defined Elite
Cadre of producers who can then claim uh
Authority uh they can also go through a
certain pedagogic uh process and a
certain set of training experiences that
then you can in in some way manage uh um
I think we and in this case the Wii is
people studying this phenomenon are at a
much earlier stage than being able to
say what we and that's how I interpreted
you as people who think about this and
think that they are in a position
somehow to affect the education of
people uh are capable of even saying
that I'd say uh as more as an observer
than an intervenor at this stage um that
what we are seeing
um is uh the beginning of
Learning uh uh critical reading uh I
think existing in a universe with many
different
inputs uh without the traditional India
of
authority that nonetheless turned out to
be right uh more often uh that
increasingly in the last few years have
shown that the more traditional uh uh
bearers of authority like mainstream
media uh are wrong make mistakes um and
here I might be a little over optimistic
but I'll say it anyway uh I think we're
beginning to see a set of practices that
are more about investigation and
intelligence gathering than they are
about seeking than they are about being
able to read the signals of authority so
if you know that a certain type face
tells you you're interacting with the
New York Times or the Wall Street
Journal in a different type face tells
you you're you're interacting with a
tabloid and that's uh and that's a form
of literacy that maps onto Authority I
think instead what we're beginning to
develop is um a much more provisional
relationship to all forms uh to all
streams that come our way uh and much
greater respect for what we would
understand as research which is taking
inputs as provisional uh uh claims of
Truth uh bearing some probability of
accuracy looking at multi
places um and then cross referencing and
coming at the end of the day still to a
provisional judgment not more than that
um and I find that enormously attractive
from the perspective of democratic
culture uh
because
cynicism skepticism not cynicism
skepticism uh and inquiry uh are the
beginning of independent thought and and
and
participation yeah I I I first of all I
I agree with the assessment that as
Levy's notion of an apprenticeship phase
implies we're learning from someone at
the moment we're learning from each
other that we're learning within
communities where ideas move rapidly
from one Community to another that
social communities of all kinds are
observing other kinds of social
practices cultural practices at the
present time and the learning curve is
enormously fast because of the
principles of collective intelligence
that I was talking about earlier that
all it takes is a few crossmembers from
one group to the other for all the
messages acquired all the lessons
acquired to take place in my blog the
other week I wrote about uh Stargate uh
which is a series on the Sci-Fi channel
that got cancelled within four days
there was a fully articulated website
involving dozens of strategies by which
fans were organizing to respond to the
decision of the network and
interestingly enough it was a global
movement within four days that is they
realized that the show was doing well in
countries around the world that it was
doing better there than it was in the
United States so why should America get
to decide whether the show stays in
production or not and so they had
templates of letters in 12 different
languages that people were writing uh in
to put pressure on local networks and
then put pressure back on the production
company to keep the show it was a global
strategy uh that was about Connections
that already existed within the network
and they'd acquired all the other
strategies that every other fan
Community the last 10 years had used all
in place within four days uh of the
ability of this community to rapidly
mobilize all those taac in response to
the Network's decision making and the
same thing's taking place in the
political sector it's taking place in
racial communities and ethnic
communities and cultural communities
that we're seeing this this learning
take place at a very rapid level that
said I'm concerned about what I call the
participation gap which is simply not
the digital divide as we talked about it
for the last decade which is about
access to technology right and we've
done a long long way toward ensuring
that every kid in America through their
schools and public libraries have access
to to the internet not all of them have
reached it right they're resistant
pockets and tribal communities and rural
areas and so forth but most American
Kids statistically speaking have access
but they don't have the access to the
kinds of skills and experiences which
enable them to take advantage of that
technology so if they if the world is of
how you acquire these skills is very
different if you live in a world when
you got 247 access to broadband in your
home and you live in a world where you
have 10 minutes of connectivity in a
local library with slow bandwidth and
you've got no ability to store what you
produce and upload it uh now we've got
we've got mandatory Federal filters you
know federally mandated filters on what
information you can access and if the
dopa act the deleting online Predators
act passes then there will be
restrictions on your ability to use
social network and blogging Technologies
in place so that the in unequal access
to these skills is a very real problem
that we have to think about so the work
we've been doing here in New Media
literacies has been to try to what are
the core social skills and cultural comp
competencies we need and how do we
ensure across a variety of platforms
young people have access to them through
schools through after school programs
through Community programs through
church-based programs through homeschool
communities it's not one top- down
solution but we have to think about what
those skills are my colleague Dr
thorburn would be pleased to say the
first and most important of those skills
is learning how to read and write it's
fundamental to anything else we can't if
you can't read and write you can do none
of the other stuff that we're talking
about also there are core research
skills that schools should have been
teaching for the last 100 years or more
about reading sources critically the
stuff that we were just talking about
but beyond that are all kinds of new
skills that are emerging as we think
about what it is to be a participant in
these online communities and those are
going to be skills Central for Comm
citizenly participation as they are for
other kinds of participation and we're
issuing a white paper in October that
will lay out what we think is a
blueprint of core skills that we think
young people need to acquire I say not
not that they should be taught because I
agree with you that they're requiring
them as much informally through outside
of school activities but they have to be
ensure that they're there for those kids
who don't have access to those
participatory cultures and whose only
access is through schools and Public
Library I share your optimism absolutely
but for the sake of U conversation and
Playing devil's advocate the AstroTurf
movement is a really good indicator that
not only do users learn quickly but that
the power structure learns quickly and
if we look at uh the last presidential
campaigns use of the blog sphere it was
brilliant it was really quite not quite
strong from both sides although the
Republicans I think did a far better job
and if we look at that's where timing is
interesting and your example of of the
Debold voting machine debate while about
a very different process the legal
process you know finally there's a good
decision but it's a year
late that's a point of concern right a
well a well-timed uh AstroTurf campaign
can throw things off just enough so I
guess that's what I'm I I agree that
these are certainly the the sharpest
skills are the ones that are emerging
bottom up but we don't really have
metrics at the moment of how pervasive
those are and um so it makes a a video
like the one we just saw which on the
one hand is is is in some ways quite
brilliant but in some other ways is also
kind of irresponsible at least at a
moment where 36 to 46% of the US
population depending on the poll thinks
that the US had active complicity
perhaps they did but that's not
translating itself into political action
it seems um
well I think I um um I think in this
regard it's
important
um it's important not to be uh utopian
and and not to and I don't think it's a
it's a question well when you say it's a
question of for the sake of the argument
for the sake of the argument it would be
to say to continue the sentence in a way
that you didn't which is and therefore
this is bad right because it's all a
question of
baselines um all are
uh decentralized non-h hierarchical
systems uh susceptable to attack sure
there are interests in any system that
are that make them that that as long as
there's drive to attack the system to
corrupt it um there will be somebody
trying to attack it the question is as
with any system what are the
defenses um in the mass media
environment
uh you have a relatively small set of
targets that require a particular set of
strategies for which these parties have
optimized uh and this is both political
parties and um uh companies trying to
affect public policy be it about
regulation perceptions of global warming
of smoking of what have you um and so we
have uh a long literature of the
corruption of the of of the mass
mediated commercial public sphere as
something that has been successfully
essentially attacked as a place where
people um don't get to express
themselves do get to be manipulated do
get to have their their their
information curtailed in all sorts of
ways so when you compare when that's
your Baseline and you ask that's why I
say no not everyone a pamper not the
Utopia but we're also uh are seeing
discreet well- defined ex advantages um
and we're seeing attacks we saw uh uh
people in Congress changing their
biographies on
Wikipedia we saw Wikipedia not allowing
anybody from Congress to uh uh from
coming from a congressional IP address
to change Wikipedia because you can't
trust them um uh just the other day
there was the story about the Democratic
uh uh uh uh the the the the the campaign
in in New Jersey where the Republican uh
uh uh uh candidate was was was
pretending to be a Dem were sending
people pretending to be uh Democrats and
crashing the attacks are are are are
there um and as with any system uh you
develop defenses um none of them are
perfect uh but I think that it's at that
level and it's the first of all it's the
Baseline is it better and second it's
understanding that it's a system with
high stakes it will be attacked and it
needs to develop certain defenses which
we're already beginning to see there's
another round of critiques of course
that's been I guess it's a almost
knee-jerk reflex we've seen it with
every medium so far where people
a construct the medium as a determiner
the technology determines certain social
structures we've seen it with the rise
of the rotary press with the
introduction of film broadcasting as
mass medium there's a whole history of
it and its latest instantiations are
people like uh Cal sunstein for example
in his notion of the echo chamber effect
or uh e olda solar pool who talked about
the kinds of fragmentation that this
this particular networked computer
technology would bring about so that
would be a critique on a somewhat more
uh structural level right that these are
about allowing enabling certain cohorts
but not necessarily joining those
cohorts together into some kind of
larger public sphere and I'm curious as
to how you would um take on those that
that sort of persistent line of critique
that uh I have my well I let me let me
go I want to before we jump into that I
want to go back to the AstroTurf
question first of all want to make sure
everyone knows what we mean by AstroTurf
which is fake Grassroots I think it's
already symptomatic of a shift in power
that powerful institutions now feel it
necessary to pretend to be bottomup
Grassroots organizations in order to be
heard right the idea that you would fake
Grassroots content and put it on YouTube
as some of the anti- gore people did
around uh you know the the undeniable
truth film this summer that's a very
interesting story uh to begin with right
that that that in the past one would
have imagined the power of governments
and major corporations to speak through
broadcasting would be sufficient to get
their message out and to change public
opinion now we're in a struggle where
they actually have to adopt the tactics
of the powerless in order to be heard at
all suggest that there's an under
there's an underlying anxiety within the
system that that the system has worked
over and over again to correct and
ensure the visibility of that is also I
think very telling and and Ben cler was
talking about the Wikipedia I happened
to run into Jimmy Wells yesterday in my
hotel in New York strange coincidence he
was there at the same time and we were
talking and he was telling me about
Steven colar uh you know normally the
sort of on the side of the people in
this struggle but apparently LED urged
all of his viewers on on broadcast TV to
go out and change the entry about
elephants on
Wikipedia and it took less than 30
seconds for the wikipedians to arm
themselves and block off any attack on
that so that they started finding stray
references elsewhere that referred to
elephant and again the wikipedians shut
this down and now the wikipedians are
monitoring reruns to ensure that
whenever that episode plays again
they're going to be ready to prevent any
attack on the Integrity of information
in that space so I think the idea that
you know that this is a war and there's
going to be struggles and there's going
to be fake stuff out there and the
analogy I drew I've drawn recently is to
Humbug a concept of the 19th century uh
where there was a kind of pleasure
people were written about PT baram Talk
of the pleasure people took of debunking
things like the mermaids the stone
giants and so forth in the 19th century
using the knowledge of the time when
Popular Science was very much up in the
air to critique this the stuff at a
period where science was in flux anytime
information is in flux there's a
pleasure in playing with humbuggery
right and then sort of debunking things
applying our knowledge pushing back on
things and so we're an era of the fake
is is real we're in an era of the lines
between fake and reality pluring and
that is its political skill instantly
this goes back to what I'm saying that
we acquire through play skills that
we're going to use and for serious
purposes almost immediately that skill
that goes from playing with reality
television playing with lonely girl 15
immediately gets applied to AstroTurf
and I think we're seeing lots of good
cases not that we're going to win every
battle but that we're seeing more and
more power emerge from the bottom up in
response to those attempts and the Very
Act of attempting to use bottomup media
to communicate political messages from
powerful groups says that the old
structures of Power are in
flux but I didn't address your question
so you wantan
um I I'm free to ignore my colleague uh
we we do this all the
time
um but the answer is the same answer uh
uh which is to say um it's a fantastic
story you told about
Wikipedia um but it also uh partly
because it
emphasizes that the
problem of uh um credibility
accreditation uh is itself an
information production problem so
everything we see about uh the POS the
feasibility of peer production of
information generally is also a solution
space available to solving this
particular problem of fiting out the
AstroTurf finding the credibility Etc um
but now to your to and and actually it's
funny because because there're two
people people here who' studied changes
of Wikipedia uh and the degree to which
the speed with which the community uses
its Force to self-correct uh uh visually
and and maybe you'll talk about that
later um
[Music]
um the Babel objection uh so
um fear of
fragmentation uh certainly uh uh uh uh I
actually there were two things one was
technological determinism which we all
have to guard against uh because if
you're actually trying to explain things
in technological terms or in terms of a
particular technological change you of
necessity are at risk of placing too
much of an emphasis on technology I have
the same risk in in doing what I do and
you always have to keep that in mind but
specifically you were talking about
fragmentation and and polarization
um that's an
empirical uh claim as opposed to a a
something that's that's deeply uh uh uh
theoretically based and I think what we
have today uh as a matter of um
observing uh uh uh patterns of use um is
uh a little bit of of Goldilocks not too
fragmented not too concentrated I don't
know about just right but somewhere in
the middle which which again as I I say
sounds a little Goldilocks like and
therefore immediately you should be
suspicious of it uh but
um we do have a decent amount of of uh
research in graph theory on the ways in
which people actually at least link to
websites to blog posts Etc which has
generated one kind of response
particularly from the people doing the
analysis which is to say no Dem ization
there's just concentration this is the
this is the this is the idea of the
power law distribution of links uh on
the web so so when you find that at the
level of the web when you find that at
the level of the blogosphere the initial
interpretation is all this democracy
business is bunk because really there
are a small number of sites that
millions of people link to and therefore
presumably millions of people see and
there are millions of sites that nobody
links to so really there's no real
democracy and that's been so for example
um um um Albert barashi uh who was who
who wrote the first piece in science in
199 uh uh working on these things came
out with the book uh uh uh um um uh
linked was it linked yes um in which he
basically says um no democracy that's
only an interpretation I think when you
actually look at this uh at this data
more closely what you see is that when
you get to relatively first of all that
sites cluster long interest you won't
find it surprising that political blogs
link to each other more densely than
they do to laundry detergent sites uh
once you get down to sufficiently tight
communities of interest but not two or
three hundreds even low thousands the
distribution tends to have a very long
visible tail but a much less Cur uh uh
but a much less Long low visibility tail
so what basically what you get is tens
or even hundreds of sites that each has
10 or so links and so there are hundreds
of entry points that are moderately
visible and the things that are
intensely interesting to people those
end up being uh uh broadcast at which
point the long the the the the the long
end of the taale the very visible sites
are no longer broadcast stations that
everybody tunes into as much as
broadcast towers for whatever it is that
the community of Interest has found is
interesting and they're visible enough
to already be seen at a higher level
cluster and that creates an attention
backbone that's very different and you
see linking across so that's how the
public sphere essentially is created
because you do have more visible sites
but the way in which their agenda is
created doesn't come from the top based
on what's interesting to Millions but
from the bottom about based on what was
interested to this particular community
of interest and this higher linked uh uh
community of Interest now I haven't done
the original research this is my
interpretation of other people's
research when their own interpretation
was we found there's no democracy uh but
but they've also but that their
interpretation is there also no
fragmentation there's too much
concentration so the fragmentation is
wrong just as an empirical fact of how
we link now the only question is have we
gotten so much that we've lost the
Democracy or are we somewhere in this
goldilock space and this is the analysis
that I think suggests that we are
actually much better off than we were in
mass media and nowhere near the
fragmentation that leads to a bab so I
wanted two two responses to the sunstein
argument the first is to read a passage
from to solo pool political scientist
from MIT who in a book Technologies
without boundaries which is his last
book published after his death in 1984
wrote predicted the following he says we
can expect that there will be a great
growth in specialized intellectual
subcultures if this happens the
complaints we now hear from social
critics will be just the opposite or the
complaints we hear from social critics
will be exact the opposite from today
we're likely to hear complaints the vast
proliferation of specialized information
serves only special interest not not the
community that they fractionate Society
providing none of the common themes of
interest and attention that makes the
society coher the critics will more in
the weakening of the national popular
culture that were shared with all by all
within the community we will be told
that we are being deluged by undigested
information on a vast unedited
electronic Blackboard and what a de
Democratic Society needs is shared
organizing principles and consensus and
concerns like the present criticism of
mass Society these criticisms will only
be partially true but partially true
they may be a society in which it
becomes easy for every small group to
indulge its taste will have much more
difficulty mobilizing Unity it's very
wise description of not just the change
in political Behavior wrought by network
computing but the flip-flops of social
critics who move from being concerned
about the power of mass media being too
concentrated and immediately move to a
cons anxiety about fragmentation or
groups not being able to talk to each
other that there's certain people who
will always be critical of the dominant
information structures of society and
they'll flip their terms readily enough
if it allows them to remain outside and
skeptical of the current development so
I think we need to be cautious about
following that criticism I think
sunstein makes a mistake only a law
professor could make no no intent but
not all of them do not all of them do
yes which is to say that he confuses all
social activity with politics which is
you know which is to say that if we
lived only in partisan political
communities on online it might well be
true the only information that
penetrates to us was those that agreed
with our preset agenda although I share
your your arguments that it's actually
more complicated than that but because
we are glass blowers and gardeners and
stamp collectors and viewers of reality
television and you know people of ethnic
backgrounds and so forth and those other
communities are clustered around other
issues the permeability of information
on the web seems to me is much greater
than a sunstein based model would
suggest and that's gets back to what I
suggested earlier about the degree to
which Civic media today may include
media that don't seem to be about
politics but which enable discussions of
citizenship and political issues that is
the most powerful spaces we need to find
are those shared spaces which are not so
rigidly defined around politics that
we're able to talk to each other across
those differences by finding other
levels of commonality and those
recreational groups seem to me play a
very important role in that process at
the present time and speaking of the
political we should probably we open
this up and uh to the
audience as opposed to this
centralized discursive Podium platform
questions from from you folks uh please
come up to the
microphone if you
do I'll ask one in the interim I've been
really curious I know you've read one
another's books were you to be embarking
on your project again any changes
or yeah I I'll start on this for once
and then be please if you're ready for
come on up for questions you know I I
think what I've learned most from
Reading uh the wealth of networks is to
really think about a more complex
terrain of participation that is if I
had a criticism of my book after reading
his it is that I'm really interested in
commercial culture and I'm really
interested in the totally amateur
sectors of cultural production in the
book that I'm looking I'm looking at the
extremes and because it comes because
I'm coming out of fan culture I'm
interested in in consumers and I'm
interested in producers what he
introduces is and really reminds us of
which I should have remembered all along
was all of these other bodies nonprofit
groups partisan groups uh political
parties governmental parties which are
also part of the political landscape
which shape how the relations between
those two groups that there's all kinds
of float between those different sectors
and Ian bogert Bist has a has done a
really long review of my book on his
blog that I've responded to and his this
criticism that hit me the strongest was
the criticism that I didn't spend enough
time talking about alternative media
that wasn't part of the sphere of
popular culture I'm so interested in
popular culture and its participation
that I lose track of these other Civic
media that are not pop culture and I
think that's what this book more than
anything else helped me to think about
in very new terms and I find myself
drawing on it more and more when I find
when I struggle with those issues and I
know through the work we're doing with
MacArthur and other projects we're
looking at that that space in the middle
is going to be more and more important
to the work that I'm doing uh you know
it's around the edges of that book but
it's not at the center of the book and
for good reasons but I think I'm much
more alert to it now well I I actually
think I just emailed Henry a couple of
days ago that in some senses I I wish
I'd had this book when I was writing and
on the other hand thankfully I didn't uh
because um it does it does uh it did
make me uh realize how much of of with
all the caveats and the efforts to avoid
it I still am very much a materialist in
terms of my
explanation um uh with all of the
efforts and that
it to be able to locate it in the
cultural would have been enormously
valuable and at the same time would have
made it very hard to Anchor the
explanations that I still cons continue
to think are right and stable and
important about the change in material
conditions that drives uh uh all of this
um and above that it's you know I I I do
my best to add as as you saw from the
one from the one slide to have my my my
my chapter on the intersection between
this and cultural production and
development of critical culture but it's
um um hopelessly naive uh uh uh and
simple by comparison um and it would
have been enormously valuable to be able
to build on this as understanding the
intersection between cultural and the
material and political conditions and
the economics driving and the business
uh uh uh environment uh on on on not on
the media business which I don't
actually work on at all so the the
intersection would have been allowed me
to do a much richer uh job or just
pointed and said here
that's true Candace hi um so I'm
interested in how your models work when
it comes to Scientific issues so when
there's some kind of translation uh
required and when people don't have
enough time to research it I mean this
idea of provisional claims of truth if
you apply that to the issue of climate
change for example um that has you know
caused enormous havoc in in the general
public trying to understand it I'm sure
people on slash dot might get it might
be able to adjudicate scientific claims
but I think it's much more difficult um
to adjudicate when you don't have a
scientific background I mean here at MIT
it's kind of the the perfect question to
ask here um because people are able to
to figure it out here but they might not
be able to in The Wider public and um I
I just wonder how those models then work
when you really are dependent on some
kind of mass media translation like
Gore's film you know it's sort of not
necessarily in the news but you know the
news definitely has played a large role
in him even wanting to do that film in
the first
place yeah I I I I would I I science is
a really tricky area and I'm not sure
that I've thought through all the
implications of it in that space myself
I certainly think there's room for
experts in all of the models that were
talking about you know I I do think that
traditional in the same way that
traditional media provides content that
gets worked through by these various
communities I think experts and public
intellectuals play Vital roles in
opening up these dialogues and giving
public the knowledge it's going to need
to to adjudicate kind of core core
questions the the network Society is not
uniquely vulnerable to this problem
though I mean you know the biggest issue
I see with experts today is the razzled
Dazzle that takes place in American
courtrooms when pseudo science Gets
drugg In by by trial lawyers and who are
unable to I don't mean this another Slam
at the law profession uh but but I think
you know you know if you look at the
ways in which say brain science is now
being introduced in courtrooms to juries
who have no ability to to deal with it a
top- down traditional expert system
didn't give us very good ways of dealing
with scientific knowledge uh when it
need when it translated into public
actions in a Democratic Society I'm not
sure a network Society gives us a lot
more other than you making it POS you
know putting a lot of information out
there that allows people to at least
read more critically but it is a problem
I I I'm not sure I don't want to be G in
my answer to that that question because
it's an area that i' I know just enough
to be stupid
about I I think it's it's important in
this case as in others always not to
compare to Utopia but to Baseline and
basine is mass media mass media culture
and Commercial mass media culture so
there's a study for example that look at
the looks at the instances of appearance
of um arguments supporting the uh
facticity of uh global warming as
opposed to arguments uh questioning uh
uh the argument and if you compare
scientific argu articles there's almost
no serious publication with any kind of
uh uh
disagreement but if you compare
mainstream media it shows almost 50/50
so what have you got do you really have
translation and literacy of the science
or do you have an effort not to
offend that embeds the concerns of the
translator rather than effective
translation on the flip side if you look
at Wikipedia and so the study in nature
that I that I showed about the level of
accuracy and the quality of Wikipedia
articles now you have a free
encyclopedia for people to go look at
that is no crappier than uh the gold
standard of encyclopedias available to
anyone freely and showing up very high
on Google searches so that you do get
the translation you get it at a
reasonable degree of of of uh uh uh
Clarity without the distorting filter
effect of the concern of commercial
media to simplify things and to make
them uh non-controversial in certain
ways and very controversial in other
ways but nonetheless filtered through
those interests so when you compare it
to that Baseline uh as opposed to how do
we really get Authority I think we're
actually um seeing uh positive
progression even on that
side my question is what are the deal
breakers both of your books and end with
um calls to action of sort uh language
about this being a critical decision um
our our conversation today has been
largely positive about um how these
things are happening despite the actions
of incumbents or other
forces
um yoka you mentioned for example
infrastructure issues uh especially Last
Mile access and this the the hope of
mesh networks and other Technologies and
addressing those shortcomings Henry
you've discussed um efforts like uh like
the dopa act that could cut off large
swaths of the population from this sort
of participation um are there deal
breakers and if so where are those and
for those of us that believe in the
cause where do we focus our
efforts goad
um
I used to be uh less
optimistic uh sometimes I almost catch
myself in moments that I say that uh
there are no deal breakers anymore which
I used to mock people who did for a very
long time 10 years ago and say no no if
I thought this was not up for grabs and
and not still affect I'd go do
Philosophy of Law I wouldn't do this
because then it wouldn't matter um but
nonetheless um I think a critical deal
breaker are trusted systems
that is to say uh a regulatory
requirement that will require
manufacturers of these general purpose
machines to turn into glorified TVs that
are well- behaved appliances that can be
trusted when they leave the factory
floor to continue to behave as that was
intended and not as their owners want
them to behave um this is uh being
driven and has been now for 5 years by
Hollywood um uh because C of the failure
of
software uh uh enabled uh encryption the
systematic persistent failure of digital
Rights Management uh over time um that's
uh uh so so the effort to move it to the
hardware uh could be a real uh stopper
because it it breaks the cycle of free
software development it breaks uh uh it
means that uh machines uh will not treat
all information equally and it changes
the Dynamics of innovation at the edges
and to the extent of what I see is
driving is precisely the
decentralization of capital uh uh of
physical capital that's Central um
depending on how it works the question
of net neutrality and Broadband access
that's that long list of things that I
that I had in the next to last two uh
are the efforts to identify those uh I
think Broadband duopoly is potentially a
problem I think the primary solution to
that is um uh open wireless
networks uh mesh networks where people
actually share create their own lost
mile Loop by sharing their wireless
access that seems to be sort of maybe on
the way I'm not sure uh uh uh uh the
viral Communications program at the
media lab is doing work on this people
doing on wireless Mesh networking here
are doing a lot of interesting work on
this but that's a potential place um
software patents could be a place where
again I'm going from physical blockages
to logical blockages to management of
the cultural uh Commons uh uh um um uh
blockages at the physical as I said both
both the machines and the transport um
software patents in principle could make
things hard in terms of free software
development and keeping things open uh
but but again in both of these layers
now
I'm a little more optimistic than I was
five years ago because I think the
number of companies that are seeing
billions of dollars worth of Revenue
coming from relying on Open Standards
building around free and open source
software um resisting uh having to uh
pay the last mile
providers um uh resisting uh uh taking
away this enormously valuable machine
and converting it into a set of special
purpose devices
um has changed the political economy so
that it's not at all clear that any of
these will in fact move further forward
software patents were stopped in Europe
because they were implemented through a
regulatory process as opposed to through
a judicial process and a little later
when there was mobilization the rise of
the counter movement of the access to
knowledge movement both nationally and
internationally now is beginning to show
the changing politics so I'm more
optimistic that those won't happen um
and so uh uh um Les's uh these are very
I mean the issues of um um
um how broadly how broad participation
will be uh how it will be skewed the
issues that Henry was talking about with
regard to uh participation skills those
could very heavily be affected by those
kinds of regulations so that only if you
have your own private means will you be
able to learn those could be not deal
Stoppers in the sense that the whole uh
uh environment what move along but but
but uh distorting
forces um so you ask what we can do uh
we can do all of these things right part
of the things we can do is what we're
already doing which is create share
adapt creative common license adapt open
licensing uh act so as to create living
proof of the alternative and to change
the interests involved so that more and
more people have an interest in keep
keeping things open or in opening things
that are already uh closed uh direct
political action um uh is the other
thing so roll your own and participate
in politics and make intellectual
property patents copyrights the various
other neighboring rights a major
political issue but again we're already
seeing that we're seeing the free
culture student
movement we're seeing in in uh access to
medicin the University of light for
essential medicines uh movements we're
seeing globally I Commons and the access
to knowledge movement bringing together
people doing access to medicines with
people doing information comment with
people doing encryption Freedom with
Librarians wanting to deal with archives
with people dealings with icts for
development um all of these people I'd
say in the last two years have begun or
think not all these people people from
all of these movements have begun to see
the connections among them and to form
connections with some companies like IBM
like Cisco like Nokia when nobody's
noticing um um and a variety of others
who see also their own interests
involved are beginning to build that
kind of a social movement at in the
first instance to prevent the use of law
of of to prevent the use by incumbent of
law to shut this down and every year or
every half decade that the environment
is still open en crunches practices en
crunches expectations and allows people
to change uh uh uh uh and allows
businesses to adapt in ways that make
this change
less susceptible to attack through law
yeah I I would second much of what was
just said um I think I think
participatory culture is here to stay
there probably are no deal breakers that
end an era of participation I think the
terms of participation are under active
debate and struggle at the present time
including who's allowed to participate
what kinds of participation is possible
what's the relationship of participatory
culture to the mass media culture that
dominate still is going to dominate the
information skar for some foreseeable
future those are important struggles if
we were to reduce since I come at this
from a cultural perspective rather than
legal or technologically I'm inclined to
read those through two lens on the one
hand there's H the threats posed by
Hollywood right and Hollywood's attempt
to protect its intellectual property
leads many of the technological changes
we were were talking about clamping down
users rights clamping down what
consumers can do extending through
technology well beyond what the law
would allow them pushing the law through
its limits intimidating consumers and
the result is going to be some kinds of
consumer practices or citizen practices
will be much harder to justify will be
pushed further underground I I believe
perpetually that people find ways to
Route Around things but they don't
necessarily route around them in ways of
equal visibility and I think something
certain cultural practices are being
shut down pretty systematically at the
present time and they're real struggles
over that uh the other side is
Hollywood's enemies right the moral
critics uh the cultural conservatives
and by cultural conservatives I mean of
course liberal Democrats um because I
think the real danger is not coming from
Republicans in the senate in the house
but from Liberal Democrats like Hillary
like liberman and others who represent I
think extremist in their desire to
Savage young people's access to
technology in return to repealing the
soccer moms you know that I think I
think the real threat politically right
now is coming not from Republicans who
of course are opposed to parti culture
but coming from Democrats who are
willing to give sacrifice it because it
doesn't cost politically a lot to go
after young people and their relations
to technology and dopa is really at the
center of that debate but it's not just
that there laws going to be passed that
will potentially block large numbers of
young people of lower income populations
from being able to connect to social
networks that are Central to youth
culture in the United States today it's
not just that people who want to protect
kids have decided the best way to do it
is not to educate them you know which I
find a really curious perspective that
is if people really belied that young
people were at risk from Myspace you
would think you'd want to bring it under
adult supervision and you provide
knowledgeable adults at libraries and
schools and community centers to help
them rather than locking the schoolhouse
date and say deal with us on your own
you know that that you know so it's
obviously not about that but it's also
the pathologization of participation
that takes place that the
criminalization of consumption that's
taking place the use of rhetoric which
leaves adults nervous about young people
who participate in the media space that
leaves adults parents teachers
principles shutting kids out of the
participatory cultures that they're
immersing themselves in giving them
unequal access to those Technologies and
those cultural experiences so it's that
war the culture War discourse both sides
are impinging on the participatory
culture both Hollywood and its enemies
are shaping the way young people will
relate to this technology at the present
time and much of the problem comes in
the crossfire between the two both of
whom were trying to you know shut out
the potentials of participation that I'm
describing in the
book um kind of building on the legality
and the political aspects of what you're
talking about um the Henry's arguing
that there's you know the the
participatory culture is gaining Pace um
and that people are sort of more
connected and more mobilized but for me
the the the deal breaker is that if the
laws don't change with this then the
people still remain impotent
maybe not at a consumer level but at a
legal level and I'm just wondering will
um you know when people live at a time
when file sharing was so publicly um uh
that the arrest of people changing MP3s
was um so publicized I think people are
afraid sometimes to exercise their
political um capabilities and I just
wonder um whether law will ever become a
bottom up
process um
uh yeah we want to put Black's Law books
in wikkipedia form and just rewrite them
as we go no I mean I I I
uh this is a deep
question um in terms of the theory of
law uh because the question is is
Law and the system for generating laws
uh
amendable to being a progressive system
or is it primarily a reactive system is
the source of law um what we usually
teach in law schools that is to say the
way legislators work the way judges
work or is the source of law first
social practice and social movement that
is then where law exerts a relatively
conservative
role in limiting the the
swings of social practice but ultimately
moves along as social practice uh uh uh
uh evolves and
changes uh to enable those
practices um uh I'm uh uh you know so
for example there there are fascinating
studies of whether Brown versus Board of
Education was really that important in
desegregation
uh whether it really played that Central
role as as uh uh two or three
generations of legal Scholars and
constitutional Scholars have really
given it that credit or was it really
the Civil Rights Movement ultimately
ratified and implemented through the 64
and 65
acts which then generated what became a
set of practices that
led to an imperfect but nonetheless much
more significant success of the second
reconstruction
that's a real question that I think
continues to be open within legal Theory
um uh in this particular case as I look
at the last
decade um law has been reactive and
conservative um and the interaction of
social practices and Commercial
practices has been the progressive Force
if by Progressive I mean moving towards
the new
stage and if I mean by it something
that's normatively attractive I analyze
the ultimate practices from the
normative perspective and I find them
more attractive and so I worry about how
do I bring law along to ratify to get
out of the way um uh but as I said I
don't think this is a solved question
within legal theory about the relative
roles of social action and formal
institutional relationship with regard
to uh uh the progressive uh change in in
in the way Society acts and is
governed I I feel a a
uh a powerful obligation to ask our uh
panelists to uh turn to the topic of
our of our of our discourse and I want
to pose the question in a really simple
simple way to get to give you both as
much uh uh see room as possible in your
answers uh essentially this we knew that
when we formulate when when Henry and I
worked on this series we knew that this
session would expand very boldly and
much Beyond questions of newspapers and
I think it's been very productive and
helpful but I would like if possible for
both of you to turn your attention
specifically to the implications of what
you've been saying about this emerging
empowerment culture uh and the uh
tradition of uh news Gathering and
information consumption that we
associate not just with newspapers but
primarily with newspapers is it a cause
of concern to you that the statistics
seem to indicate that in a generation or
two there will be no more newspaper
readers is there any evidence that you
can see uh that indicates that this
participatory and atomistic and special
interest um uh uh culture that's
emerging in part because of the way
they're empowered by the internet will
generate institutions that have the kind
of equivalent
uh significance for society including
the significance that Ethel P mentioned
in that precient comment that Henry
quoted uh uh the the question of whether
or not the the the uh newspaper role as
a as a centralizing force as a unifying
force as a as a socially defining force
uh will have any will have any
counterpart in cyberspace in other words
does the fate of newspapers concern you
and in what ways yeah first of all it's
someone who trained as a journalist
years ago I'm deeply concerned by the
fate of newspapers and I think they
continue to play a vital role in the
culture that we were describing for me
part of what's healthy about convergence
culture is it has both the centralizing
power of mainstream media and the
diversifying power of participatory
media that it's the interplay between
those that I think is what makes the
present moment healthy Rich it's the
skep it's the blogosphere versus the
newspapers that's more interesting to me
than either of them by themselves it's
the degree to which the blogosphere
forms a corrective process not just
questioning what newspapers do but
dispersing information from one
newspaper throughout throughout from
multiple newspapers through a community
if we think about what blogs do around
information they form around groups that
feel that they're not represented well
by a single traditional News Channel and
they began to suck in information from
multiple directions and to still them
for that Community they're communities
that are chronically underst served by
traditional journalism if I was a
journalist I'd study where the blog I'd
study the structure of the blogosphere
and my that especially it touches my
constituencies and figure out which
groups I'm not covering and which issues
I should be dealing with and try to
respond to that quickly because the
bloggers sphere is a symptom of the the
kind of unequal coverage different
groups receive in your Society but
they're very dependent still to a large
degree on mainstream news channels to
provide the raw materials they're
talking talking about I think it's a
fascinating moment where mainstream
provides that shared framework we use to
talk to each other about we then pull it
into these different Niche publics that
debate it haggle over it reinterpret it
reappropriate it Innovation
experimentation Discovery takes place
within those communities and then top-
down media monitors that figures out
where that experimentation goes on and
pulls it back into the mainstream so
that we could argue that participant
culture diversifies then mainstream
media amplifies and that's true of news
and information where we talk about
newspapers and citizens or it's true
about television when we talk about
media producers and fans that both of
those systems are in place and I think
the challenge is to figure out the
relations between them at the present
time I think where're yes there's a
moment where they're competing I think
that eventually we're going to work
through those relationships in ways that
are mutually reinforcing Yokai I hope
you'll respond too but I wanted to ask
Henry a partial followup don't you think
that it would be helpful if the terms we
use to describe these conditions did not
already carry a normative value because
the good side is participatory and the
other side is top- down other words even
the terms in which the the debate is
framed by the forgive this uh descriptor
by the utopians seems to me to tip the
balance and it seems to me not actually
an accurate way of describing the kind
of contribution to our society that
newspapers like the New York Times or
the Washington Post make nor the
contribution to our society to our
Democratic Society that local newspapers
make to their local Regional communities
I think that their endangerment is a
matter of great concern because I don't
see the equivalent of of a the
equivalent institutions emerging uh in
in other environments even though I'm
I'm certainly not in favor of force
feeding anyone information that they
don't want to again yeah I don't I I
certainly am not suggesting that citizen
journalist will somehow replace
professional journalists there's
questions of training there's questions
of resources there's questions of time
there's questions of access there's
questions of Ethics they make that a
very unlikely Prospect and a very
undesirable Prospect and I certainly
didn't mean to imply newspapers were
purely top down they play very vital
roles in communities I just simply think
that the categories of news that have
been constructed over the last decades
aren't adequately responding to the
diversity of the culture and part of the
reasons newspapers are in crisis is that
the and why blogosphere is taking off
the way it is is because they're
identifying points of underservice are
points where diversity hasn't been
reflected adequately in papers and I
think that's true in some ways of the
New York Times as is it of any other
paper it's there's no one newspaper can
serve the full range of constituencies
in our society today and so corrective
mechanisms are emerging to allow for
that diversification of perspective to
take place but I don't I think that that
diversification would not be well served
if you took the the power of traditional
journalist out of that equation I think
it's a very important function that we
still we still
need
um it's obviously a very complex
question um uh I think first of all it's
important that you in your followup uh
broke already down things which was
going to be the first part of my answer
anyway um The New York Times The
Washington Post The Wall Street
Journal uh play a particular
role um and they're as you call it dear
to us because we're the elite and
they're the elite vehicle and they are
top down um and you don't have to be
apologetic about it because um we do
have placed great value on expertise on
learning on um uh dedication to reasoned
argument and we do think that it's not
all about participation all the time no
matter what anybody says we do exert in
our society a certain value and we give
certain weight to expertise and things
that come top down in the social in the
way that we stratify Elite versus uh
non- Elite and I think those uh three uh
uh uh uh in particular serve a role as a
common platform for Elites to form a
common discourse and a common set of
insights um and a common set of
conversations and that function doesn't
disappear that function of here's the
place where where the elites come to get
their sense of what the other people in
the elite are reading that continues to
play interestingly by the way those
three relatively insulated from the
market forces operating every elsewhere
because of the particular family
structure uh uh of ownership that has
allowed them to remain insulated
comparatively to other media that have
not been able to sustain that role
because of the pressures uh uh to
massify what kind of aite do you think
they
are when you use the word aite one
implication is an elite is uh is is
illegitimate just because it's you don't
mean that there Elites of knowledge that
we they Elites of knowledge they're
Elites of wealth they're Elites of
political power they're the people who
have a much higher probability of
getting things done the way they want to
get them done in a society that has wide
disparities of power to effect and some
power is economic power and some power
is power of institutional role and and
expertise and some power is political
power and and there are different Elites
in this country and they all read the
same three
papers um uh and and that's an important
function of these papers and that's
going to continue so the New York Times
might begin to curate all sorts of blogs
and things like that but that will
remain in that same functional when you
start talking about local genuinely
local
papers given that the web is global it's
actually not that trivial to identify
platforms that will self- select for
Geographic proximity newspapers are
perfect for that one of the things
that's interesting about the times is
that a place where they're not so much
suffering uh uh in advertising they're
not seeing which is what I had expected
and when I asked it turned out
surprisingly on the local uh uh papers
that the that the network that they own
they're not seeing that much removal of
advertising and so the ability to be a
again a platform this time not for the
elite but for the geographic proximity
that is not not easily done through the
web the local papers if you look at
boston.com become a potential place
that's a platform for things to happen
on the net again because the thing they
bring is this so again you need to look
at the particular markets and the
particular players and what they play on
the other hand you know television
changed
newspapers um the internet changed them
again in terms of getting them back into
the business of fresh
news um uh uh much more than than they
were in in in in in certain periods um
uh and so they'll have to move the one
last point I'd like to make that is a
little orthogonal but I think important
and that goes to professional
values we all know and have all read
about the pressures between the business
side and the journalistic side I just
noted the fact that these three Elite
papers have a particular business
structure shared among them that
protects them from the business
pressures and allows a much uh uh a
buffer between the market and the
journalistic values uh that drive them
and that's uh quite special and
surprising that it's true of all three
um um I think in this regard an
interesting place to look at is a is a
josh Marshall in talking points memo
because there you have a Blog completely
dedicated to journalistic values using
the fact that he does not need millions
and millions and millions of dollars to
live he can live in his apartment from
relatively little advertising will not
take any grants from foundations only
based on Advertising because he's
committed to showing that a journalist
committed to journalistic values can
build a platform to work with his
readers to investigate to find opinion
to clear it on a Model that is self-
sustainable for initially basically one
guy and now he's been able to hire two
or three more committed to journalistic
values bringing what he learned as a
journalist to journalistic values and
the one data point about how important
that might be in the future is I used to
talk to people about how much when I
talked about free software about how big
the software Services Market was as
compared to how big the software
publishing we think software we think
Microsoft and we think copyright but in
fact that's about a third of the
software Market 2third of the software
Market are software services and each of
those thirds by the way is bigger than
the entire movie industry and recording
industry put together in terms of annual
revenues what I recently found out that
that number of two3 of the software
industry being software Services hides a
much more interesting fact that's
relevant back to journalism and the Josh
Marshalls of the world half of that that
say the size of the entire software
publishing industry is
independent
Consultants so that's another place to
begin to look at where journalistic
values people who dedicate themselves
elves and
learn can begin to become professional
sites as individuals collections of two
or three serving as the Professionals in
conversation with a peer production
system I realized we're running uh short
on time so I wanted to just invite each
of you to maybe just um prognosticate
briefly on the impact of the things
we've been talking about here for higher
education Henry I know you U mentioned
the MacArthur series on digital learning
and their attempts to kind of M that in
in very deliberate ways um it seems to
me that the future is going to be
fundamentally kind of hybrid um
involving participatory culture informal
learning the kind of things you're were
talking about um but these kind of
spaces and the kinds of Institutions
that you are all affiliated with
continue to perform an important
function so what will be the nature of
that hybridity well I I mean I I would
imagine the relationship of universities
to Learners is being roughly comparable
to the other traditional institutions
and the Grassroots energies we're
talking about I I mean that this podcast
you know this is being webcast this will
be podcast it'll be out there bloggers
can point to it and form discussions
around it it becomes resources and
communities it will be listened to
around the world literally in this new
environment as opposed to being held
within the locked doors of uh MIT so
that what even the policy of the Forum
which is always free and open to the
public there's nevertheless constraints
geographically that would prevent this
discussion historically from being heard
in that way it's now out there and
indeed in the culture of open courseware
we're seeing more and more of that stuff
flow flow their way out as Prof you know
I started my own blog this summer uh and
as I start to write that I've had people
write well this is the next step from
open courseware which is in sense
conducting seminars on the web that is
creating a space where the quality of
discussion and not just the contents of
discussion become part of something
that's open to a larger public and I
think that's a real role we play that as
we have the luxury of spending time
writing reading thinking we can play
that role in a public discourse that
engages a variety of different
populations out there and be the sort of
goet be you know take our power as
amplifiers to tap the diversity of the
web and make it more visible and to make
sure that certain conversations get
heard that otherwise would get buried
and I think that's a very important
function for an academic it's very
different from the service I play for
pay for my salary here in this room for
MIT is I think we now have an obligation
to be educators of a larger public in
this participatory culture that we're
involved
with I agree that it's very important um
to
uh
um allow uh uh uh much greater access to
what we produce that's accessible I
wouldn't want to underestimate uh the
difficulty
ities uh for one uh one of the great
barriers to access uh to what we do is
the fact that uh we speak the way we do
um and it requires quite a few years of
learning to even uh uh process uh uh
what we do so there's a so there there's
I'm acutely aware of this in particular
um uh um so that's a real barrier
um
there are question of what we could do
inside institutions of Higher Learning
how we can structure our own materials
so that they're more participatory one
of the things I've tried to do with the
book and it's much too early to tell
whether it's worthwhile or not is not
just make it available for free download
but embedded in a Wiki that ideally
would allow people to make notes to give
counter examples and case studies one of
the things I loved was 3 days after the
week Wiki came up maybe a week or two um
somebody who is active in Wikipedia
wrote back and said on page so and so
you said that there are no that
Wikipedia is not a traditional Community
I said it in relation to Elan ostrom's
Claim about what's a community it
doesn't matter but I said it's not you
got it all wrong because you looked at
the 60,000 you should look at the
communities around definitions that's
where Community occurs that's where
people know each other I learned the
thing became a learning object in
conversation with people who it's
talking about um I don't know it's an
experiment we'll see
um structurally we offer places that are
relatively insulated from the market and
insulated from having to deliver
specific things with specific times this
has made um uh uh institutions of Higher
Learning
important support bases for contributors
to peer production be it acad mic
contributors to free and open source
software be it um uh students
participating in all of these things so
we become an important source of as it
were the equivalent of the IBM that
employs the people who participate in
who participate in peer production more
generally we're the we are a fairly
stable uh enormous
industry that doesn't need to
appropriate what we do and therefore an
enormous place for people to exist who
participate as members of social uh uh
uh uh of of of social processes but with
the learning the Traditions the
commitments uh and so potentially very
valuable both stable and in terms of the
values uh we can bring um I think uh uh
uh uh what MIT did in the open
courseware initiative was uh
fundamentally important because it came
at a time when practically all
universities were thinking of everything
in terms of
how do I repackage and increase my
Revenue flow how do I appropriate this
uh and this was the first University
that said no no no no no how do I use
this to further my message my my my my
role of public education and that was an
important moment and I think we see it
now in the move to open access
publishing and plusa uh uh public liary
of science um we're beginning to see
early stages very hard to take what we
learned here and Port it into patents in
the biological science
to rededicate the university to
providing its output as a basic input
into open uh uh uh science and
development and implementation so that
things can reach uh the edges so we can
be so so so we can begin to see these uh
uh occurring elsewhere um but as I said
I think we shouldn't
underestimate the degree to which
universities are
conservative the degree to which there
is deep disagreement within the
university on the transition away from
what started in the 80s towards more
business-like
model and back towards at least the
self-conception and now the feasibility
of practice of dedication to the
education and learning in the interest
of the public well just you raised open
course bur and let me say something as
an MIT faculty member I'm a True
Believer in the open course where
Mission I think that mit's leadership is
fundamentally flawed in this area
by its unwillingness to stake out a very
strong claim for fair use that is I
think MIT had a position where it could
have said we now are educating the
entire world via MIT the rights that we
exer as Educators in a classroom to
distribute materials quote materials
reference commit materials ought to be
extended to our educational mission to
the society and we should be defending a
much more broad definition of fair use
that allows materials to be circulated
rather than taking the most narrow pyune
notion of copyright and applying it to
every piece of material that passes
through open courseware if I'm going to
give my materials away for free as an
MIT faculty member to the world and I'm
sort of expected to do that as part of
my role within MIT then I want to be
able to actually represent fairly my use
of other people's materials through my
classes through open courseware and as
long as open courseware is not doing it
I've made a principal decision as an MIT
faculty m not to participate not cuz I I
give all my most of my writing away for
free on my home home page but I don't
believe in participating in the system
that MIT has bungled leadership on in
terms of not defending and not defending
fair use uh as being fundamental to that
educational mission that we haven't gone
nearly far enough to think about what it
means to really create an participatory
knowledge community that MIT is at the
center
of here
here
thank you both very much I mean this
this is the first face to face I hope
there are many more this is a terrific a
terrific conversation thank you so much
thanks for inviting
[Applause]
me